you know if i if i read some of your
books like if i read who rules the world
the book that you wrote
uh who rules the world uh if i watch
your documentary if i watch some of our
interviews if i go watch you and
william buckley have a debate if i go
watch
any of the stuff that you've done a lot
of work your catalog of work is very
wide
and very deep i don't get the most
positive feeling about america almost if
i had someone who was not
an individual who had spent a lot of
time wanting to study
uh the history of america say i have 50
students here and i have 50 students
here neither one of them have ever
studied the history of america if i gave
him your material
to read and study for your i'm willing
to bet
most of them after you after you would
probably hate america
you know a lot of the things that i read
it doesn't come across
as there is that that love of
what a great country america is for you
and you make a lot of good arguments in
your books i'm watching to see what your
points are on this okay this makes sense
i see where he's going with this
do you still maybe it's not even still
do you think america has
or is ever been the greatest country in
the world
there's no such concept as the greatest
country in the world
just as there's no greatest human being
in the world countries
have many complex characteristics
some of them very outstanding
wonderful others hideous so
take some other country let's take
germany
some of the greatest thinkers scientists
artists in the world the depths of human
history
as well what's more it flips quickly
from one to the other
you just can't make comments like that
i'm in his journey
in the 1920s germany was regarded as the
peak
of european civilization and the
sciences
philosophy the arts was regarded as a
model of democracy
the 1930s 10 years later
was regarded as the depths of human
history
10 years later beginning of a return
to what it once was so what's germany
what's england england has an absolutely
hideous record of atrocities and
destruction
for centuries iran in fact is a case in
point
i know a lot about it but
iran could have moved in the early 20th
century
towards democracy and freedom the
british
crushed it when iran tried to
take control of its own energy resources
in the early 50s
britain tried to crush it by force
when they were unable to they asked the
big guy across the atlantic to come in
and smash it for them
okay that's one side of britain not the
worst by any means
on the other side it has again
my favorite philosophers in history
right in front of me i have a book
about the friendship between adam smith
and david hume in the 18th century
two outstanding figures to
my famous figures in history so that's
another side of england
so what's your attitude towards england
you can't answer
just too many things same with every
other place you can think of
so i don't see any except for people at
patriotic
rallies i don't think you should ask
questions like
uh what's the greatest country
so would you would you be able to say
you know you 60 years you've given to
mit most of your life you've lived in
america you've been all over the world
would you be able to say i love my
country america
i don't love countries love
is a relationship between people
when you love countries there's
something wrong
should you have loved uh germany
when it was carrying out the holocaust
uh should you have lived germany when it
was at the peak of human civilization
uh you care for people
on the societies in which they live i
care for
many societies including this one but
you don't
love countries
i don't think you should i think there's
an emotional connection sometime with
certain set of values
that one nation offers to you where the
other one where you grew up and didn't
it's almost like a i'm not
i'm i wasn't born here i'm not a u.s
citizen i can never run to be the
president here or maybe i can do
governor or something like that but this
is not really where i was born
but this country welcomed me with open
arms and gave me an incredible life and
uh to compare to where i was raised at i
mean you know the worst day in america
is still 10 times better than the best
day in iran so that's what i mean where
maybe for you you had some kind of a
love for the country that you know gave
you the opportunity to become the
country
sorry the country didn't give you the
opportunity
certain people within the country gave
you the opportunity
while preventing others victims of their
own crimes
from having that opportunity they gave
you the opportunity
because you were a refugee from a
country that was an official enemy
okay that's what they did
take me my parents fled
from eastern europe
horrible conditions and did manage to
get to the united states
and they managed to
create a good life for themselves an
even better one for me
okay on the other hand a couple of years
after they fled from europe
they happened to make it just before the
first world war
few years later in 1924
the united states passed a law
immigration law of 1924 which was aimed
particularly
at jews and italians some jewish
the idea was to keep jews and italians
away from the country because they were
not up there we don't want that kind of
rabble around
well that helped put most of my extended
family
into gas chambers okay they couldn't
come here
because they were bored in the 1930s
they can refuge jewish refugees
continued to be bored
or virtually a few were let in in the
late 40s when they were still in
concentration camps
but then desperately trying to get out
the united states wouldn't have central
americans who were
victims of massive u.s atrocities
were being kept out right at this moment
they're being driven away from the
border when they flee from
refuge from horrors that we created from
the 80s
okay so it's a very mixed story sure i'm
glad to have been able to come to the
richest country in the world with
advantages that don't exist anywhere
else
thanks to the extermination and
expulsion of the native population
so yes for me that's very good does that
mean i
love the country no i admire some things
within it
i think we should despise other things
within it and the same is true of every
other country
so if you like this sort of short club
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye